you are also among many things a martial
artist both judo and jiu-jitsu
how has this helped make you the person
you are
so i mean i was a competent club player
in
judo and grappling i mean i was you know
by no means any kind of a superstar but
it was i went through a few phases with
it where i did some i'm when i was
quite young a little bit more when i was
17 i am and then i got into it kind of
seriously in my mid-30s
and you know i went pretty far with it
and i was uh you know pretty good at
some of the things that i was doing and
i did appreciate it quite a bit where
and on the one hand it's always if
you're gonna do exercise or something
it's a more motivating form of exercise
if someone is if someone is crushing you
you're like motivated to to do something
about that to up your attributes and be
better about getting out attributes yes
but there's also that sense that i'm you
know i was not i was not a sports guy i
did do wrestling in uh in junior high
and i often wish that i think i would
have
i would have been good for me if i'd
carried that on into high school and had
a little bit more of that i mean it's
like i i you know filch a little bit of
wrestling vibe with always going on
about in great embracing the grind and
like that push that i associate with the
wrestling team that that i in hindsight
i wish i had gone through that and
pushed myself that way
but even getting back into judo and
jiu-jitsu in in my mid-30s as usually
the old man on the mat with that there
was still the
you know the sense that i
you know working out with the the group
and having the the guys that you're
beating beating each other up with it
but you just feel good coming out of it
and i can remember those driving home
aching in various ways and just thinking
it's like oh that was that was really
great and
i you know it's mixing with a bunch of
people that had nothing to do with any
of the things that uh that i worked with
you know every once in a while some
would be like oh you're the doom guy and
i but for the most part it was just
different slice of life uh you know a
good thing
and i i made the call when i was 40
that's like maybe i'm getting a little
old for this i had i had separated a rib
and tweaked a few things and i
without any really bad injuries and was
like have i dodged enough bullets should
i you know should i hang it up i went
back uh i've
i've gone a couple times in the last
decade trying to get my kids into it a
little bit i didn't really stick with
any of them but it was fun to get back
on the mats i really hurts for a while
when you haven't gone i
gone for a while but
i still debate this pretty constantly my
brother's only a year younger than me
and he's going kind of hard in jiu jitsu
right now and i you know he was just he
won a few medals at the last tournament
he was at competing yeah and i was
thinking yeah i guess we're in the
executive division if you're over 50
or over 45 or something and it's not out
of the question that i go back at some
point and do some of this but again i'm
just reorganizing my life around more
focus probably not going to happen i'm
pushing my exercise around to give me
longer uninterrupted intellectual focus
time pushing it to the beginning or the
end running and stuff
yeah yeah running in calisthenics and
some things like that but it allows you
to still think about a problem but if
you're going to a judo club or something
you're you've got it fixed it's going to
be seven o'clock or whatever 10 o'clock
on saturday uh although i talked about
this a little bit when i was on rogan
and shortly after that carlos machado
did reach out and i had trained with him
for years i back in the day and he was
like hey we've got kind of a small
private club with a bunch of
executive type people and
uh
it gets it does tempt me
yeah i don't know if you know him but
john donahue moved
here to austin
uh with gordon ryan and a few other
folks and he has a very interesting way
very deep systematic way of thinking
about jiu jitsu
that
reveals the the chess of it the
the the like the
the science of it
and i do think about that more as kind
of an older person considering the
martial arts where i can remember the
the very earliest days getting back into
judo and i'm like teach me submissions
right now you know it's like learn the
arm bar learn the choke i
but as you get older you start thinking
more about it's like okay i really do
want to like learn the entire canon of
judo it's like our all the different
things there and like all the different
approaches for it not just the you know
if you want to compete there's just a
handful of things you learn really
really well but sometimes there's
interest in learning a little bit more
of the scope there and figuring some
things out from you know at one point i
had wasn't exactly a spreadsheet but i
did have a you know a big long text file
with like here's the things that i
learned in here like ways you chain this
together and while when i went back a
few years ago it was good to see that i
whipped myself back into reasonable
shape about doing the basic grappling
but i know there was a ton of the
subtleties that were just that were gone
but could probably be brought back
reasonably quickly and there's also the
benefit i mean you're exceptionally
successful now
um
you're brilliant
and the problem the old problem of the
ego yeah
is i still pushed kind of harder than i
should i mean that was i was one of
those people that i yeah i'm i'm on the
smaller side for uh for a lot of the
people competing and i would you know
i'd go with all the big guys and i'd go
hard and i'd push myself a lot and that
would be one of those where
i would i
you know i'd be dangerous to anyone for
the first five minutes but then
sometimes after that i'm already dead
and i knew it was terrible for me
because it made the no it meant i got
less training time with all of that when
you go and you just gas out you know
relatively quickly there and i like to
think that i would be better about that
where after i gave up judo i started
doing the half marathons and tough
mudders and things like that and so when
i did go back to the the local judokai
club i thought it's like oh i should
have better cardio for this because i'm
i'm a runner now and i do all of this
and didn't work out that way it was the
same old thing where just push really
hard strain really hard and
and of course when i worked with good
guys like carlos it's like he just the
whole flow like water thing is real and
he's just like that's true with judo too
some of the best people like i've i've
trained with olympic gold medalists and
for some reason with them everything's
easier everything it's
you actually start to feel
the science of it the music of it the
dance of it and it's ev everything is
effortless
um
you understand that there's an art to it
it's not just an exercise it was
interesting where i did go to the
cotacon in japan kind of the birthplace
of judo and everything and i remember i
rolled with one old guy i didn't didn't
start standing just started on
groundwork nuaza and it was striking how
different it was from carlos he was
still he was better than me and he got
my arm and i you know i had to tap there
but it was a completely different style
where i just felt like i could do
nothing he was just enveloping me and
just like slowly ground it down and took
my arm and bent it while with carlos you
know he's just loose and free and you
always thought like oh you're just gonna
go grab something but you never had any
chance to do it but it was a very
different feeling that's a good summary
of the difference between jiu jitsu and
judo in jiu jitsu there's it is a dance
and you feel like there's a freedom and
actually
um
anybody that's like gordon ryan one of
the best
the best grappler in the world nogi
grappler in the world uh there's a
feeling like you can do anything
uh but when you actually try to do
something you can't just magically
doesn't work but with the best judo
players in the world yeah it does feel
like there's a
a blanket that weighs a thousand pounds
on top of you and there's not a feeling
like you can do anything you just you're
trapped and that's uh that's a style
that's a difference in the style of
martial arts but it's also
uh once you start the study you
understand it all has to do with human
movement and the physics of it and the
leverage and all that kind of stuff and
that's like
yeah that's super fascinating at the end
of the day for me
the biggest benefit is and the humbling
aspect when another human being
um
kind of tells you that you know there's
a hierarchy or there's a
um
you're not
that special yeah and in the most
extreme case when you tap to a choke you
are basically
living because somebody lets you live
and that's that is one of those if you
think about it that is a closer brush
with mortality than than most people
consider
and that kind of
humbling act is good to take to your
work then where it's harder to get
humbled you know
yeah because nobody's nobody that does
any martial art is coming out thinking
i'm the best in the world at anything
because everybody loses
you